thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a well
groomed wild ride with Stevo if you know
Workaholics or any number of other
humongous shows and movies then you know
this week's guest under's home and man I
say well groomed because we're right
outside this guy's house he's gorgeous
and his lawn does get groomed very
briefly but man is this guy just willing
to tell us juicy stuff like for example
the Workaholics movie got
green lit like production ever they're
ready to go into it and then at the last
minute they get screwed they and none of
them were happy about it and we're gonna
find out just how unhappy about it is I
don't think any of these guys have ever
gotten into the cold hard juicy truth
about how crazy that situation was and
that's just some of it so strap on your
seat belts ladies and gentlemen and
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Anders home
what's up this is a score dude I'm super
stoked to have you man this is a double
score because I'm like
scoring points just being here man yeah
at your house basically yeah at Mike rib
by the way I did say uh uh I told my
wife I'm like yeah they like come to you
they got this mobile situation and she
was like is it like a big crazy van I
was like nah there's no way they want
that attention so like don't sweat it
and then I come around the corner I'm
like
texting her like so yeah I was wrong uh
you'll see it and my kids are like whose
van is that with the big butt
yeah daddy's work friend yeah I'm uh
kind of done with the whole Stevo in my
face all over the bus it draws a lot of
attention yeah and so we're gonna take
paint rollers to it you gotta do like
somebody else uh until you get the
seasoned assist and then you just rotate
to somebody else you know what I mean
like share who the [__] ever Garth
Brooks yeah Garth Brooks I was thinking
about like you know uh
something Plumbing there it is there it
is yeah just hella plays on words though
we're like we'll clean your pipes out
from behind I don't know it's like FBI
surveillance it's not funny like that
not FBI
yeah Yankee face yeah so uh so dude it's
crazy
um this this upcoming weekend of of uh
box office
you got
two huge comedians going I wonder if
there's ever been like a battle at the
box office like this for comedians Bert
kreischer's the machine comes out the
same day as your movie about my father
yeah Sebastian Maniscalco both these are
two Stadium stunners both good dudes too
yeah uh I mean obviously I got to pick
my movie with Sebastian but like um
and I almost think there is some overlap
audience wise but I feel like it's two
different worlds I don't think they'll
be competing because Bert's is just like
balls to the wall Insanity uh I haven't
seen it but as far as I can tell and
then Sebastian's is very like not
wholesome it's got some like it goes
there but like it's a very wholesome
father son almost like uh rom-com yeah
which I had when I when I read it I was
like oh this isn't like the guy chasing
the girl to like make it up to her this
is like the guy trying to prove to his
dad that like he raised him right and
it's it's good yeah I mean you can you
can
frame it any way you want but there's no
way around it this is uh mud wrestle uh
they should mud wrestle this weekend or
next weekend yeah this is a Clash of the
Titans and there will be one winner
someone's gonna have to lose in this one
and what's crazy too is that both Bert
and Sebastian have the same management
yeah yeah dude she told me I was like so
who are your other clients because I saw
her last week and she was like Bert and
I go oh right on I didn't even think
about that right so she might have to
dress like two-faced Batman style like
one suit on this side one on the other
like my manager is at levity as well and
he said when I brought this up that
Judy's
um kind of feels very uh
I don't know I mean I'm comfortable a
little bit like nervous about it and I
said well you know what Judy is is in
this situation she's the mom who had two
kids playing the Super Bowl right yes
and and Adam said I'm gonna tell her
that it's a win-win yeah she's the MVP
exactly I mean unbelievable because
neither of those guys were funny
um no like she she's the MVP she knows
how to pick them find them because like
being a manager you can find somebody
who's super talented right but then to
pick someone who also is willing to like
have a vision and work on top of the
talent like you don't find those guys
too often and uh those two are
workhorses man yeah on top of everything
she's gonna make a [__] load of money
this weekend she doesn't care about that
stuff though
show friends show Friends
um it's uh I mean it's amazing yeah and
uh Little Mermaid
get the [__] out of here with that [__]
I mean it is very misogynistic I I wrote
a whole paper in college about how
disgusting I had disgusted I was but you
know the premise of The Little Mermaid
let's get this straight is that she has
to give up the puss without saying a
word
you're a woman your job is not this is
what we're teaching young young girls
your job is not to even say a word you
have no voice you shut up and give up
the beef what grade did you get on the
paper
[Music]
the premise or that you did a paper in
college what's going on here
I made it
um back for a second year as a freshman
and was gone by Thanksgiving out here in
California where was it I was at the
University of Miami and yeah nobody's
nobody graduates from there right I mean
it um
within one week of class starting I was
um placed on Final disciplinary
probation
uh relocated in the dorms yeah like when
you went to the school for the first day
were you like dead set on finishing or
were you like yeah this is gonna be my
year then it's that night the first
party happens and then you're just
[__] it's like when you get your
license and you're like I'm never gonna
drive drunk yeah
this is amazing
where's the road
right how long did you have your license
for before you got at the UI oh
um I
got my license
um when I turned my birthday and
uh my birthday in 1994
less than a year yeah I got my first DUI
within less than a year I'm starting to
drive and I got my second DUI within one
month of getting my license back first
consistent
and then you know what I did I quit
driving
there it is
you know you got your priorities
straight I had a homie in high school uh
who we had like every two months we had
something called a b day and a b day all
the teachers met at the beginning of
school so students showed up uh like two
hours later right and whenever it was a
b day you'd go to somebody's house you
drink before school and you go to school
kind of hammered and my buddy got a DUI
on the way to school like hit some car
and parents I guess they just didn't
know that we did this my parents were
like I think he's got a problem he was
drunk on the way to school I'm like we
were all there I don't know what
happened huh crazy oh
but yeah he was 17. so he's in the same
wheelhouse right but never got the
driver
you uh
seemed like a guy who always got away
with it
um you know what I'm not a guy who got
away with it I'm not that like clever
I'm a guy who pushed it just enough like
far enough until I was like all right
what am I doing here this is kind of
crazy
um and then there were other things
where I just absolutely didn't give a
[__] and people teachers parents would
be like come on just like
yes I'd be like it doesn't matter yeah
I'll just figure something out you know
uh but I I like I had stuff going on
like I was a swimmer and like I was like
I'm just gonna swim my way into college
which is what I did I was like a real
[__] uh real [__] bag bad student and
just kind of like
weasel my way in that and I was like
okay I'm here
still was just like a bad student in
college I thought I'd like reboot you
know like start over like Rebrand uh
that didn't happen uh
but then I discovered like uh you know
what I'm start like trying to write
movies and stuff and like then uh after
graduating from college was like okay
now I'm gonna move to LA finally Rebrand
you know and then I just met three
losers like myself and uh yeah the rest
is my history yeah I remember
um
seeing uh you guys at the on the red
carpet of The Comedy Central roast of
Charlie Sheen uh-huh that was like right
when the Workaholics came yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and uh man it's it's turned into quite
the quite the career dude it was um
the game changer and like the best gig
too because it was like
we were like doing sketch comedy uh just
[__] around like
you know same as you guys kind of like a
crew that just was like let's roll on
this you know
um
and then after like six or seven years
of doing that uh got the show and then
the show just
was exactly what we needed was what was
exactly what a lot of people were
looking for and uh the success was
like perfect if you were able to do
creatively what you wanted to do like
everything everything and not only like
uh as far as like scripts and like
stories we pitched and stuff but just
like
you knew that if you were going to
improvise something you could say the
craziest [__] ever and then like
nobody would be like whoa hey man can we
can we talk to you for a second about
that like what are you talking about
your your landscaper's doing a great job
out there
you know I gotta just like just slip him
like a ten dollar bill
you know we're pretty we're pretty
loosey-goosey yeah on this whatever we
uh you know we don't mind you can hear
it a little bit you live in a gorgeous
neighborhood you like to take care of it
there's freaking Lawns that need to get
mowed like I'm not gonna tell this guy
he can't do his job all right like come
on yeah this is reality
um
but it would be nice if he wasn't doing
it yeah it's all good man yeah is that
because Comedy Central
let you guys do whatever you want we
were nobodies like they were I was just
saying this is somebody the other day
like uh Nick Swardson hilarious stand-up
comedian in all these funny movies uh
Reno 9-1-1 got his own sketch show and
they were like giddy up here we go and
they kind of were just like
super Hands-On with that and we had a
budget of like 650 Grand an episode
which is nothing for them wow
maybe three oh yeah yeah well that's
just like Speedos though
um but so you know with production and
like Gaffers and sets and all this [__]
right right right you know you're you're
still figuring it out and like they just
didn't Bank on us uh not in a negative
way they just were like yeah let's give
these kids a shot
um
and
you know I we we got to make exactly we
wanted uh the way we wanted to make it
and uh just had the best time going into
a Workaholics did you did you guys have
this like special feeling that you guys
knew that it was gonna be as big as it
was
so will I am song I Got a Feeling was
based on a conversation we had
on top of the Capitol Records building
one yeah yeah
um
no like our feeling was
we think this is funny and like we are
pretty hard on each other as far as like
that's not funny you know what I mean
like right man we can do better and uh
we loved it we had a good time we
thought we were doing things that
um hadn't been done on TV yet
we started doing like these little
adventures for every episode it was less
sitcomy and more kind of like
action comedy but just like shrunken
down in scale
and uh push the envelope a little bit we
were relatable you know we were like
just dudes who wanted to like meet girls
and drink beer and like keep their job
and not get fired yeah how did the the
Seth Rogue and the Zac Efron's come into
the fold was that like after the show
was already out and they were fans of it
yeah yeah I mean um we we dipped in we
dipped our toe into like the stoner
comedy world right yeah
um and so like the overlap with Seth's
fans uh was a thing so then we were on
his radar
um and so they brought us in to do
neighbors they had a montage where it
was like our fraternity comes from a
long line of people who've uh
like created wonderful things for like
the world of partying right and it was
like in the 50s it was these people 60s
of these people I think we were the 70s
and we invented like beer pong
um but I think like The Lonely Island
guys were like from the 30s or something
it was a bunch of like right
recognizable comedy people that in a
rapid fire succession
um Illustrated this fraternities history
historically speaking I've not always
been that great with my diet or my
health but lately man am I doing really
well at filling in any gaps because I do
not go anywhere without my ag1 from
athletic greens and it's just important
this stuff is delicious I'd love to
start my morning with it and it is
comprehensive and convenient daily
nutrition and by daily nutrition I'm
talking about everything that you need
it's really important to me right now to
make sure that my diet's in good shape
I'm not eating too much I'm getting
everything I need because I'm taping my
bucket list comedy special in London
England on July 14th and I want to look
my best I want to be thinking my best
and this helps with my cognitive ability
I want to my gut health I mean dude this
does it all and if you want to get five
of these
convenient comprehensive travel packs
plus an entire year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin D then get on over to
athletic greens.com
Stevo where with your first purchase you
will get five travel packs and that
vitamin D for a whole year and I'm
telling you I swear by it like I said I
don't go anywhere without it so one more
time go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo to jump on this deal and let's get
back to it
man so that was pretty fun when you said
invented ping pong I just had this this
picture of you know like in in Thailand
they famously have these women that
shoot ping pong walls out of their
private parts I've never seen that yeah
I I elected to not go to that yeah but
um but I just thought like man whatever
it might have been funny if they showed
you guys in like the way you invented
ping Powers
she ran out of the old pooping it out
um yeah I don't know I think the way we
did it was okay
no it was uh that would be great
different movie that's actually more
hour speed like uh which we did game
over man right and I got to be in it it
was so rad man that was the best we're
like uh will you jump off this thing
you're like this is what I do
no problem
uh and Seth produced that and uh helped
us kind of like shape the story from
what it originally was which was like a
telephone with like a bunch of
celebrities he got taken over and then
we just had to like dial it back because
like it just was gonna be a scheduling
[__] nightmare to have uh so many
people and all that but uh no we were
lucky to get you guys ah dude we loved
it party boy let me tell you this too
you do different things and you never
hear about it you know like you can kind
of like you can get a sense of how big
something was yeah whether you hear
about it going about your day right I
heard about that when game over man came
out I heard about it everywhere I went
dude I said like that got viewership no
it did you know it's crazy
they didn't they they would never tell
us how many people watched it what they
did tell us was that it was number one
for two weeks in a row which back then
is a different game but like they didn't
have that even back then they didn't
have a movie that was number one two
weeks in a row and then they like uh
they buried it and so like to find it it
you had to like type in game over and it
still wouldn't even pop up wow until you
got to the comma or the man and then it
would be like all right fine I guess you
want to watch this insane movie with
people getting dicks cut off and heads
are exploding and all this stuff yeah
um but they never told us how many
people watched it but Adam had a meeting
with somebody uh who was pitching a
movie there and they were like man I
guess your guy's Movie killed it Han he
was like yeah I don't know and the guy
was like yeah they showed me like this
Shard of like the biggest movies the
middle movies and the movies that didn't
do well and our movie was up there with
like the [__] giant Sandler movies
and like those types so
you know Netflix after the strike let's
talk I don't know yeah by the way that's
the whole thing strike like we don't
know how many [__] views we're
getting from these streaming companies
like how do we know what's a hit or not
besides word on uh word on the street
Word of Mouth why what are they
protesting during the strike stuff like
that well yeah you used to kind of know
like based on Nielsen ratings like how
well a show is doing it wasn't like
behind closed doors where if you created
something they'd go yeah no it's it's
doing well and you're like right how
well
very well it's a blessing and a curse
though because that does shield you from
failure I want to know about failure you
learn you can learn from failure if you
learn from success but they don't let
you they don't afford you that
opportunity uh but no on top of that
um it's like doing a YouTube video not
knowing how many views it gets like I'm
just gonna leave this here like no but
is it yeah it's crazy I applaud your
response to that I think that that's
fantastic like it's crazy part of me is
just so sensitive that being shielded
from failure sounds good but I also
relate to that but like you're a skater
right so like I always look up to
Skaters because I can't skateboard
um at all but like it's based on failure
like you almost always fail like even
when you're just going somewhere you
might eat [__] right
um but you get back up and it's still
just kind of part of yeah
part of being a skater is falling
couldn't agree more and what's crazy too
is that when like a skater is in public
and they try and do a trick they're
trying to get they don't make it there's
like a like haha you want to laugh at
him right but when you walk by the
basketball court and you see someone
throw the bag they don't make the hoop
you know that's true yeah like you want
to pick on skaters we should go to a
basketball court right now see how that
goes but you suck yeah you know like
later for sure oh man you've been uh
actively at the the picket line with
pretty like I just went the other day I
was doing press for the movie and then
came back in town and hit it up and yeah
like it's so funny man I posted a
picture of me uh with the sign letting
people know about what's going on and
they're like oh you had to post a
picture to show you were there and it's
like
I'm posting a picture
to promote the movement of what we're
doing right then I get people who are
like [__] you you're rich and I go I
know
I had some guys like tell us how much
money you got I got millions okay
but I'm there for the people who were me
before that don't have the millions that
deserve the millions right like it's a
community it's like it truly is like you
know this town's not that big like
it's a big city but like when you get to
a certain point like we all know each
other and there's new people coming in
and people leaving
and uh you gotta kind of fight for each
other and like the things we're looking
for is just like
the pay scale has changed the the
industry's changed everything's altered
and yet the way people are making more
money now we're getting paid less and
yes I'm talking about me but I'm talking
about people who are also just like
getting their first gig well they're
where they're making like uh
uh you know maybe they're making like 50
Grand yeah they're making it in like a
month or two because that's just how it
works but they might not have another
gig for a year or two because it's tough
right and they need to get this
insurance and all that kind of stuff
um
so we're fighting for that we want like
a little more transparency you used to
sell things into syndication right so
like it'd have its first run then it'd
be on like MTV or something like that or
USA and you get paid again because
there's more ad dollars
and so like you get paid x amount the
first run then you get paid y amount for
the second run but now these things are
just living one place forever right and
you have residuals yeah and so like you
aren't getting that long money that you
used to get even though it's still there
in a long way
um and then everybody made fun of my hat
I had a hat with like a long thing to
protect my neck I get [__] about my hat
I can't win can't win did Adam get get
any Flack he had a sign about gays or he
did everyone every homophobic person in
his
following or whatever just went in on
him and he was like wow I would picture
it be the other being the other way
around where people were saying that
that they were offended on behalf of the
gay guys no because Adam's pretty gay
not good yeah you know what I mean so
like the dudes in his chat in his
comments were just like we can't lose
another guy we love you you can't be gay
uh and he is that's classic he's pretty
gay
um did Adam's mom know how prominent
Adam's weiner was in game over man
before the premiere I don't I don't know
actually he might have I think he had to
have warned her he had to have warned
him no she was there I know that he
acknowledged it I just can't remember if
I want to say that he said
that during the premiere when he was
like naked he was sitting next to his
mom and maybe she like put her hand on
his leg to be like oh my gosh but at the
same time it's like well don't do that
either like that's not the way to
express this I could be wrong but I
think that's I I I've vaguely recall
that something like that where like it
was acknowledged and he was like just
don't even acknowledge it just watch the
movie yeah the uh man it was great and
congrats on the success and and thank
you again for letting me be a part of
that
um yeah
it feels still pretty recent that there
was a Workaholics movie in the cards
with uh I'm guessing Paramount plus
because it's a Viacom Comedy Central
connection yeah and uh
it was green lit all ready to go people
hired and like you know schedule on and
then they it just got shut down at the
last minute
yeah like literally wrote the script uh
we were ready to go we had the cast back
and all scheduled and everything uh we
rented stages and then when they came
back from like uh
in the into the new year like that first
week they were like we've got a whole
new Global agenda right which sounds
dark uh and maybe it is but they've got
a global agenda where basically like
the amount they were going to spend
making our movie our
um intellectual property just wasn't
worth that to them because they were
worried that it wasn't going to appeal
to International markets right they
thought it was going to be uh like the
only really hit in America and they
needed two Niche two Niche and look
I get it I get it but like
tell us that a little sooner sure tell
us that a little sooner but also like
I'm I'm I'm I'm I feel bad for those
guys over there because Paramount plus
is imploding and when we were working
loading yeah yeah yeah wow I I am
um here comes a can of worms but uh the
um our jackass forever yeah the last
Jackass movie just went to Paramount
plus yeah and and it went to Paramount
plus
um like without any form of of a video
on demand uh window in advance right and
it went to Paramount Plus without any uh
establishing the market value by by uh
bringing it to other streamers it just
they didn't offer it anywhere else they
just sold it to themselves and uh and
there was speculation that
that that was not legal you know I know
I don't doubt it I mean that's the whole
thing this is why we're striking because
everything's changing so quick like the
rules are being made up as they go
everyone plus didn't exist when we
negotiated our contract exactly and then
all of a sudden here it is oh really I
didn't know that you're gonna get paid
if it went to Netflix but it didn't it
went to Paramount right because Viacom
right the the the the argument was like
that that it's not fair like had they
taking it to Netflix and gotten an offer
taking it to you know like HBO Max like
whatever and then then they would have
established a market value for it they
would have understood what it's worth
but because they did not do that they
just sold it to themselves presumably
they didn't like uh rip themselves off
if there's anything I know for sure
about jackass it's that they did not rip
themselves up they really actually look
out for themselves pretty darn well and
speaking of ripping off in the second
season of Jackass I ripped off every
darn hair on my body with wax it was a
pretty iconic bit if I do say so myself
and you know what dudes with Summer here
I mean almost here is it 2
is it important
to make sure that your body is not
covered in disgusting hair I'm telling
you and you don't have to rip it off
with wax that's what manscaped is for
you got manscape products just making
sure that you're confident and ready for
summer and boy are they hooking up the
Wild Ride listeners right now with the
manscaped
performance package 4.0 it comes with
the lawnmower 4.0 which is the
waterproof cordless trimmer you've got
the weed whacker 2.0 which is for the
nostril hair and the ear hair man
there's nothing more humiliating than
talking to a chick with a bunch of hair
coming out of your nose think about this
guys the performance package has
everything you need loaded with crop
preserver ball deodorant crop reviver
ball toner I'm telling you man they've
got it all and especially in the Summer
with the chafing the the manscaped
anti-shaping stuff dude nothing hurts
more than chafing and nothing's more
embarrassing than chicks thinking that
you are ungroomed so go to
manscaped.com and use the promo code
Stevo to get this very important
performance 4.0 package and by using the
promo code Stevo you get 20 off your
order plus free shipping man I love
manscaped you love manscaped jump on
this deal support the podcast and have a
killer summer looking really good one
more time
manscaped.com promo code Stevo now let's
get back to it
notorious for this and they never they
never Syndicate shows for the most part
except for South Park which has like a
different deal uh they like they don't
like to Syndicate which is what
television the whole thing is based on
like you said okay so you can make more
money and make more episodes and
subsidize by the way welcome to
Hollywood minute uh [__] and it's
just strange because like uh it feels
like they're just in quicksand man like
people are getting laid off the people
we were in contact with as we were
developing it we'd be like Hey where's
Greg they're like
Greg is someone we don't speak about
anymore like people are just like
disappearing consolidating and you're
like yikes what's crazy though is that
with the uh you know situation and with
the jackass forever
um like they've really kind of looked
into the situation I don't even think
they had to look terribly hard I think
uh
Dave England Googled how many uh
subscribers they have on the Paramount
plus platform and I was shocked that
they've got like they had like 30
million and then I feel like we got
Yellowstone that like uh they don't
though
they make Yellowstone but Yellowstone's
not on Paramount plus because I was like
I gotta watch this [__] Yellowstone
everyone's talking about it and then
when I went on Paramount Plus for
Yellowstone
it wasn't on there it's on something
else
I don't know but it's crazy to uh I mean
I don't know Siri where is Yellowstone
streaming
when it comes on it has MTV Productions
you're right it says Paramount Network
but I wanted Yellowstone has MTV
production one in the beginning it used
to be Spike
but okay whatever he's like
yeah Spike TV whatever whatever it is
um it sounds like Paw Patrol that's
their [__] cash cow every every
subscription they have is because the
kids are like what um plus yeah Paw
Patrol and shout out to Paw Patrol when
I when I was downloading like Paramount
plus the like it had like a two-star
rating like
yeah I mean I had yeah I'm just mad that
they didn't give me like a VIP login
that's all you wanted yeah that's it
that's all I wanted because you make me
feel special the UFC gives me a VIP
login yeah it is one of those things
where like when you when you fly like
you pay everything to fly first class or
whatever they're like here's a hot
washcloth and you're like this is very
nice and then you open the washcloth
you're like this is a rag but the
gesture right makes it feel makes me
feel special yeah yeah and I am
personally offended that
and from my perspective yeah they've
done you dirty yeah they've done you
dirty on the Workaholics movie and I
know that you guys were uh kind of
putting it out into the ether that what
you wrote is awesome yeah and that like
that you're amiable open-minded to
another entity so here's the thing is
that they go hey by the way you guys
have I think it was two or three weeks
to find a proper Suitor for this because
if we couldn't do that they needed they
did pay us it was a pair play so we got
paid uh
because you know they held us off the
market kind of thing and I did write a
script but so they said you got three
weeks because if you guys don't find
somebody before that we're gonna write
it off we're gonna we're gonna use
everything else to write off for taxes
The National Enquirer catch and kill
dude it's [__] crazy and I go yeah
man hey I'm glad someone's there
crunching the numbers so that uh you
guys are are making ends meet but like
what the [__] is happening
it's just gonna take our baby into that
the whole if
like who's the guy
who's the [__] guy who got a raise
for being like you know what if we play
Ridiculousness for 12 hours a day
we're gonna do better than if we play
anything else right and they tried it
and it worked and I'm not dissing uh uh
ridiculousness ridiculousness obviously
like they get eyeballs but for someone
to program for someone to be lazy enough
to program a 12-hour block of just
Ridiculousness Monday through Thursday
or Friday or whatever the [__] it is I
think catfish is now sneaking in there
because that's a wonderful show as well
but
you guys can't come up with new stuff
right did teenagers stop getting
pregnant it's okay come on come on it's
so excited about it it's so lazy and
like look I get it uh
but to me it's like doing free throws
from down here yeah it goes in more
often but like I want to see you take a
[__] half court shot because when it
goes in everybody Goes Bananas yeah I
don't know man
um what else sucks so the presumably
those three weeks elapsed those are over
those are gone they they did the catch
and kill and by the way the whole thing
is like if you're Netflix there were
people who were interested but they
would have to
buy they'd have to pay for the movie and
then at some point it would go back to
Paramount plus and no one's gonna do
that right we're in the forever business
now so they would do a licensing deal
with Paramount essentially yeah yeah and
so what what is that two years three
years
against Infinity years you know what I
mean like
I mean what's next for these
conglomerates I know they don't know
they don't know they have no idea if
they had an idea uh [__] wouldn't be so
wild right now eight like Max is coming
out this week HBO Go
HBO now
HBO Max and now Max and that's just been
like in 24 months
the difference is that there's more
companies underneath this umbrella and
more content so you have to subscribe to
each one separately right no so so
they've like gobbled each other up so
the new one will be Max and by the way
free commercial for you Max you did it
way to go
um but like they just went through this
whole thing of like glomming up other uh
entities and all that stuff to compete
against everything else it was time
and then it was uh ATT bot Time Warner
and then it became like uh Warner
Discovery but discovery's got this cash
like what from like the fishing shows
yeah right and that's [__] crazy
unreal I think people zero in on the ATT
buying it as like the where everything
went sideways because at T just it was
not their Lane and they bought it and
then it everything well I only buy like
HBO or whatever for like one or two
shows then I'm like [__] I'm locked in
now I got all these different apps
because I want you know I want to watch
different shows dude I think they [__]
up I think there are certain brands
where you're willing to pay for what it
is right and HBO has that audience and
has that brand where they're like we
make we have
four or five Elite shows on at a time
right for a certain kind of demographic
it's all you should be just be that
people will pay
for that yeah because they because it's
the best show it's the best TV
succession uh Game of Thrones when it
was on like [__] house of the Dragons
pretty dope
curb like they had these Elite [__]
shows that are doing things that uh
other people aren't doing and they're
doing them well they should have just
been like we're good we're over here
we're doing our own thing
right because like I don't know what
you're
you're not competing with bigger you're
competing with better
unbelievable wisdom in that don't
compete with bigger compete with better
and there's even more wisdom in not
letting bad habits get bigger but
replacing them with better and that's
what fume is all about what's a fume
it's something that I care carry in my
pocket everywhere I go it is a device
that helps you replace bad habits with
good habits and by bad habits I'm
talking about chemicals even drugs you
know what replace those with flavored
air yeah it's what this is all natural
plant powered device for flavoring air
how about that
I love to get behind giving up bad
habits and that's why I
got this relationship with fume but I
didn't think I needed a fume because I
didn't I I quit bad stuff a pretty long
time ago even though they sent in my way
and I'd like it so much that I'd keep it
in my pocket all the time and I think
you're gonna like it too and if you've
got that bad habit and maybe a bad habit
that you think you should quit that I
think you can agree it's time to try
fume and it can't be any easier it's try
fume.com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and if you go to
trifem.com and use the promo code Stevo
then you get 10 off your journey pack
and that is all you need to get on this
journey to knock off the bad habit and
get onto this good habit very healthy
nothing unhealthy about it and I think
you know who you are if you need to quit
so go to trifum.com use the promo code
Stevo you'll be glad you did now let's
get back to it
when it when everything's easy right
there's no other app that's easier than
the other one now right
like it's easier to go to McDonald's
than it is for me to go to uh a [__]
like high-end burger place right that
takes time that takes money but these
all cost the same they're all right at
the end of my clicker but if one's
better I'm just gonna go to that right
but what about like also are you worried
about movie theaters getting bought out
by like Amazon Productions or Netflix or
like because aren't movie theaters
you're starting to like that's tough
that's tough too but you get there's the
advantage of like Amazon gets to
distribute like smaller movies that
might never get uh these are all new
negotiations that nobody's ever thought
of
you know
um yeah with with your new movie about
my father yeah is uh in theaters on May
26th yeah yeah that's right and then and
a damn [__] funny movie too did you
see it my screener wouldn't goddamn work
but my executive assistant is raving
about how [__] hilarious it is it's
funny and he's um
describing different scenes yeah uh the
the skateboard then next year I'm gonna
make you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh my God I mean he's describing like
he's De Niro's super funny he's raving
about it yeah De Niro's super funny in
the opening he's he's dressed like he
was so the whole thing is it's based on
like Sebastian's relationship with his
dad uh first generation immigrant from
Sicily to Chicago uh and now Sebastian's
meeting this she's met he's met this
like super honky waspy girl and he wants
to marry her so the Italian immigrant
father is like I got to meet the family
and I play like the the douchebag soon
to be brother-in-law type guy and they
go and they stay with these Blue Bloods
in like Virginia or some [__]
um
and
so they do in the beginning of the movie
they flash back to the 80s to kind of
set the table for where Sebastian comes
from and his relationship with his dad
and De Niro's like fully 80s stuff I
don't want to get too detailed about it
because it's he looks insane
um and it's just so funny to see the guy
from like Casino Goodfellas like these
Taxi Driver like Cape Fear these serious
movies and he's in this [__]
ridiculous outfit it's so funny too
because in a lot of those early movies
they uh made him to look old but it
sounds like now he's old and they're
making him to look young right man yeah
he's done it all it's wild but so yes De
Niro Sebastian mascalco Kim Cattrall
plays my mom Leslie Bibb plays my sister
uh Sebastian's love interest this kid
Brett Dyer plays my little weirdo
brother who's super funny and then my
favorite guy who plays my dad is David
reishi who's on succession he plays um
Carl
yeah he's so funny he's so [__] funny
in this movie just like
in a way
remember like American Pie uh Eugene
Levy Dad yeah kind of like came out of
nowhere yeah and everyone's like who's
this [__] guy and like Canadians no
SCTV and you know people some people
knew SCTV back in the day but he kind of
just like exploded and I hope David gets
that because he just like steals every
scene like
just a comedy animal
I love it yeah is there uh
dreaming component where like you know I
don't know yet I think it's a it's a
theatrical run uh it's a studio Lions
Gate Lions game okay
um
so wow that's the machine is Lionsgate
too
I don't I don't know about that machine
movie [__] bird Crusher
um yeah I mean I'm sure it is you know
lionsgate's a smart production company
they should they should make uh my movie
um yeah I'm sure they're gonna have a
big weekend but uh
yeah it's gonna be I don't know what the
streaming component is I'm sure like
maybe they were smart enough uh to just
wait and be like well we just killed it
at the box office who wants it now I
mean indefinitely informs what a movie
is gonna go for on a streamer right how
it did at the Box Ops yeah yeah so dude
you're preaching the choir I just the
business end is like there's part of you
who's that's like oh man they're they're
doing this to me and then the other part
is like well I should be smart enough to
like figure this [__] out right right
but I'm not I'm not smart enough so
we'll see how it ends how crazy was it
working with Robert De Niro like Holland
point is he on the set is he just ready
to go uh there's not like an intensity
it's almost just like a
uh he's just chill does he ever [__] up
his lines uh yeah yeah but like
um
he also just will roll with stuff too
like if something you know if somebody
like drops a plate this now becomes part
of it you know and he's got things so
cold that like uh he works it in you
know not that that's like a superpower
but like he does it very naturally
um and he's and he's just like he gives
himself to the director this is my
second time working with him which is
crazy I worked with him on a movie
called The Intern a few years ago
and he was the same there uh our
director Laura teruso on this movie she
was in charge and not like a drill
sergeant but like Robert De Niro the
icon of acting was looking to this
fairly new filmmaker to be like and now
what do I do what do you want from here
like it's great you I'm the paint you're
the brush like let's make this happen
and like
I try and be like all right man if
that's De Niro and he's giving himself
like that you gotta just like roll with
it like if she wants you to try
something you don't think it's funny or
gonna work
[__] try it and do your best at
making it work and then they'll either
use it or not you know what I mean yeah
it's not the me show
with the internet comedy was that with
Anne Hathaway with Anne Hathaway it was
like a light drama where Anne Hathaway
was this kind of like um
girl boss CEO of this uh clothing
delivery upstart thing I played her
husband uh kind of like taking care of
the kids at home and then De Niro is
this elder guy who takes an internship
at this company oh was he like tired CEO
guy yeah he worked in business for a
while and he he saw how it was buried
like just a juxtaposition type thing
where it's like I come from this world
this is the new world guess what
everything from the old world you know
we don't need to throw it all out like
some of it's useful and Anne Hathaway's
character like took advice from that and
then also he learned things from like
the new school that kind of thing
um
yeah and it was a sweet sweet movie
killer airplane movie just like
everybody was like I saw that on the
airplane everybody nice yeah and you had
to heard a lot about the inventing Anna
one yeah that was like a [__] rocket
just like everybody saw that I loved it
yeah I really enjoyed it the story's
crazy yeah that lady's just next level
and that we're in this world where like
if you've got the cojones so you've got
the balls to like just go out there and
say you're somebody
people will believe you because everyone
is scared to like miss the bus right so
she's like
the whole story is that like she's
trying to open this exclusive club and
if like you're not in on You're Gonna
Lose and like this culture of like young
Geniuses or whatever you want to call
them in New York with ideas that could
be the next Uber or this and it's like
you better drop a million now because
it'll be worth a billion in 10 years so
people are just like ah here take my
money right and then these kids are just
burning through it and being like yeah I
live for 10 years like a boss but uh
things didn't fly sorry you know what
was this yeah
the story of Anna soriken uh it's on
Netflix it's called inventing Anna yeah
and uh durs over here was was epic as
the uh husband of
the protagonist she's like the end so
there's like a the way they package the
story was Through The Eyes of this
investigative journalist who's trying to
figure out who this woman is who's 24
and is convinced all these huge mega
Banks and like major players in New York
to give her millions of dollars to open
this essentially like Soho House yeah
right and on the eve of her like getting
all these people to like give her the
money
things are starting to not add up and
like this is the backstory of her like
getting loans from this bank to like pay
this person back and like it's a whole
[__] mess and she basically like digs
herself deeper and deeper and deeper
into this hole of like lies and stuff
and ends up getting arrested and the
investigative journalist uh kind of
Maneuvers her way and to interview her
in jail and just losing her mind and you
know and my honors is the the husband
who's instead of dealing with the
Fallout of the intensity of this uh his
pregnant wife being so immersed wow yeah
what a role and Anna klumsky plays the
investigative journalist
um uh Gardener what is oh [__] uh she's
on Ozark she's like yeah yeah yeah uh
god well this was years ago now right
yeah we don't need to do too deep anyway
she's amazing as this as this woman and
everyone's like what the [__] is this
crazy accent that you're doing right
because it sounded so bad kind of but
then when people would hear the real
girl speak she was like from Russia but
doing a fake accent at the same time so
like the way she was speaking was kind
of crazy Julia Gardner
um is the actress uh so she kind of had
to like go on talk shows and be like
this is the way the girl talked it's not
a bad accent that I'm doing it's a bad
accident that she was doing right um but
so when you got the the comedy stuff and
you're able to do the drama stuff like
that's a huge yeah drama's been the new
like you know there's just fewer
comedies also there's just fewer
comedies getting made
um but yeah I did this uh this movie I
got a show called Muppets Mayhem that
just came out last week on Disney plus
you should check out with your kids
um that was comedy and I play like this
streaming executive type douchebag at
the record label
um and then I'm dipping my toe back into
drama and doing this Godzilla show for
Apple TV plus nice uh that'll be out I
think like October or November I mean
it's amazing and epic to be able to
I mean I'm super lucky to like have
these opportunities and
um it's like the more opportunities you
get the more like people go oh we did
something different maybe he could do
the thing he could be we think he could
be good for here or we see him a
different way so yeah I'm trying to like
just put another arrow in the quiver you
know what I mean
um doing it sooner is better yeah right
by Adam Sandler
I don't know that anybody saw him do
anything really dramatic you know he had
the we had the one where his punch drunk
family died in 911.
oh yeah I mean yeah I never saw that
gemstones or the uh dude
I think his serious roles are dude
that's unbelievable yeah that Gambler
movie the uh
just [__] there was it made you so
uncomfortable and it was so great but I
mean all of these examples came decades
into his career yeah right like and then
it was a curveball yeah you know like it
was rad I keep hearing that uh Netflix
movie he did where he's like a
basketball coach was awesome that was
good I saw that yeah people were saying
it's like great
yeah it was good yeah it was really good
yeah but isn't that crazy like a great a
good movie with Adam Sandler a lot of
people are like yeah I don't even know
what that is but the thing is like If
Ever I see Will Ferrell or Adam Sandler
in a serious movie I'm like oh this is
gonna be good
you like Will Ferrell serious yeah like
the one where he had the voice in his
head I really like that I can't remember
that oh and he was uh yeah yeah and then
the other one where he was like a
straight [__] drunk and his family
was leaving him and he had the yard sale
on the front yard like I mean like you
just know he's a good [__] actor I
gotta see that it's good it's real tough
especially when you have like a specific
brand of Comedy that comes from like
your essence right like so when Sandler
is like yelling and Billy Madison and
he's like
you're like oh that's hilarious
but then when he does something dramatic
and he's yelling and you hear yeah the
same thing it triggers the laugh but
you're like oh no this is how this guy's
crazy
oh oh [__] he's like losing his mind
right now yeah it can't it can
and I'm sure it's Will Ferrell Jim
Carrey like these guys uh will have
these brands of Comedy that we almost
ingrained in our own brains and like
repeat their jokes and all that stuff
it's hard for them to shake yeah that
and be like no I'm actually screaming
for like I'm in pain or whatever yeah
you know I mean Eternal Sunshine
Spotless Mind like yeah it's a lot of
people's favorite movies yeah
you know yeah I mean you just know I
think anybody not anybody but like a
comedian who's that talented to be that
funny is talented enough to make a
really good solid yeah
cerebral movie yeah are they except
Rodney Dangerfield
for sure although it was pretty good
with Natural Born Killers but yeah
are they still
um gauging like the the effect that code
like the cover like when when jackass
forever was coming out yeah yeah they
were like the they had an actual number
like the the like public level of
comfort for going to a movie theater is
at like 80 now right right right and
then like the Omicron came out like
right yeah right you know and we got
pretty screwed by kovitz
over now yeah yeah yeah I mean if you
believed in it to begin with
um
yeah it's it was never here um yeah I
mean it's it's gone I mean I feel like
we're in a post Tom Cruise top gun
Maverick world now right we're like that
movie did so well that everyone's like
okay so people people will go to the
movies now uh but what will they go to
see
um I don't know I went not that I
haven't gone to the movies but uh I'm
like saw Top Gun saw the [__] new
Avatar movie uh I've seen a bunch of
movies in the theater Fair
are you guys still doing the podcast
yeah with that this is important uh it's
me Adam Kyle Blake and uh we just shoot
the [__] every week essentially every
week yeah yeah it's a good time and
they're like so that started during the
pandemic because we were like we gotta
do something right
um
and we couldn't see each other so it was
like a good way to like link up we were
doing it over Zoom
um you know because we're all working
all the time like I was in Mobile
Alabama making this about my father
movie Adam was Atlanta Blake was in
Vancouver Kyle's all over uh Kyla was
playing pickleball
Kyle's just like destroying his body
playing pickleball uh you play that
right I I've played with the TK yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [__] I mean
it's a way of life uh there's actually a
couple courts around the corner that
I've gone to and uh with our neighbors
brought us and we went down there and
they're like What's Up Guys hey it's
five bucks ahead but also we got free
sangria I made some old-fashioned mix
like who want and I'm like are we about
to get smashed down here
um candidly Vinnie over here thinks he's
better than everybody
yeah and he reached out to TK said hey
we're gonna uh we're gonna record a
podcast with Anders yeah can you give us
anything juicy anything to do and
what did TK say it's like nah dude this
guy's squeaky clean he said he said well
he is turning 42. yeah ask about After
parties and that was really about it
I found out that you're kind of a
sneakerhead so that kind of interested
me yeah I mean so I see what you're
doing here yeah I like those yeah those
are great I wore them for the reason
okay there we go yeah no I got my eyes
on New Balances a little bit yeah for
sure
um but it started with Workaholics when
um
you get famous right and then people are
like hey come on buy the Adidas showroom
and you go
you know and you you go to Adidas and
they're like so take what you want and
you're like oh I'm gonna walk out here
with 10 pairs of kicks and like three
tracksuits you know
um and they were super cool and that
kind of just kicked off like having too
many shoes right yeah and then I was
like all right well I like New Balance
too so let me get back into this mix and
now it's just out of control we're
trying to get Steve lifts up with New
Balance yeah yeah I mean I Rave I just
bought the the new New Balance Carhartt
collab oh nice I'm super particular
about
um not having
um animal you know like leather like
they got vegan if they got if they got
synthetic New Balance then I'm down it's
like we're going to The Warehouse New
Balance if you're listening
I've been wearing uh basically just my
Niger my Niger Houston Nike
Skateboarding Shoes yeah because they're
vegan and I love them sick dude yeah
Dave
um
well so dude it's get to the [__]
movie theater on the 26th of November it
is crazy to be back in the movie theater
too yeah it's been like streaming
streaming streaming streaming for a
while right yeah
um yeah like I um I I love Bert yeah I
like my I'm managed by you're on the
bird train I get it that's fine I I
manage my levity I I feel for Judy I'm
stoked that she's the Super Bowl mom
yeah
um I wonder uh like we I wonder if
they're giving out screeners for the
machine that's a big indicator
if they're letting right predict see it
if a movie sucks dick then they don't
let the critics see it interesting
and I I
I know for sure that your Murphy
doesn't work interesting we gave you a
screener but it didn't work
for my executive assistant okay you know
what I think it was though is that is
that like I got two email addresses like
one like that I'm really precious about
say them into that camera man say them
into that camera
it it came into my my main email address
and then I was like oh I gotta sign up
and create an account for this I'm gonna
use my burner email and I think because
the email addresses didn't match it got
shut down right yeah so it did work like
my assistant but didn't I said dirt bird
didn't send you a screener I did not see
a screener interesting dude I got the
link I'm gonna just watch it tonight
yeah oh you got yours yeah Isaac is
[__] I know I'm excited about how
goddamn good it is yeah it's funny it's
funny everybody's funny it's a feel-good
movie too like I said it's a rom-com but
it's between a father and a son you know
I mean all the things that have never
been said uh get said uh you know and
it's about like
recognizing yourself and your parents in
in sometimes we do that in bad ways when
you get older you're like God damn I'm
turning into my [__] parents I'm
doing this I'm doing that I'm definitely
turning into my dad wild right yeah but
then you go
but the the great thing about my folks
I'm doing that too and like he's got to
make sure you focus on maybe both of
them I guess I don't know yeah but yeah
a lot of laughs a lot a lot of laughs I
mean dude I believe it and be sure and
check out
um Muppets Mayhem on Disney plus it's me
it's Lily saying Taj Mowry SAR chaudry
um and the Muppets all the [__] the
band what's the wrexum football club
Ryan Reynolds thing is that on Disney
is on that is on Apple because doesn't
Rob have an apple show yeah Mystic Quest
yeah yeah Robin I think Rob is Apple
yeah yeah okay yeah well we'll figure it
out there's so many goddamn streamers
but there's no subscriptions to the
[__] movie theater so go to the
goddamn movie theater it's easy and
watch about my father yeah Make Some
Noise get [__] wild yeah have a good
time get in there and [__] do a
number three yeah
I mean
that's the best Robert De Niro joke of
all time I think I was doing a number
three yeah
all right man well [__] thanks for
having me good to see you guys yeah I
appreciate it yeah yeah nice to meet you
this was fun all right so so we're on
the other side and if there's anything
that that you're not comfortable with
like most of that has to go
was that a well-groomed episode of The
Wild Ride podcast or what now
you guys who stick around to the end of
the episode you you always know how
grateful I am for you and this week I
want you to know that I'm grateful for
more than just my street team I'm
grateful for my sister and I cannot
believe that I'm about to say this but
my sister and I now have matching
tattoos my sister waited until she was
over 50 years old to get her first and
only tattoo which says right on her arm
something positive just the words
something positive and now my arm says
the same thing it's in my niece's
handwriting which is special I have a
matching tattoo with my sister and my
niece
and that's a big deal but not a bigger
deal than my street team so guys this
one this one is extra
meaningful if you go ahead and take that
screenshot of however you're consuming
this podcast post that screenshot and
tag our boy Anders home and uh let them
know that you appreciate him it would be
a good look for me I love you guys so
much thank you and Cindy wind I love you
especially
everybody